will we see Drax and nebula and all the
rest after the Guardians of the Galaxy
drop their third adventure and what's
the deal with will poulter's Adam
Warlock here's what you need to know
about what seems to be James Gunn's
final film in the MCU
after a controversial phase four The
mcu's Phase 5 kicked off in March with
Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania the
film sets up some huge Stakes for the
MCU by introducing the new Big Bad Kang
of the Conqueror however after all that
Multiverse Madness Phase 5 will shift
its focus from the quantum realm to
Nowhere as a saga of Star-Lord continues
Guardians of the Galaxy volume 3 has had
a long road to theaters as everyone
knows director James Gunn was fired from
the Guardians movies in 2018 after a
politically charged controversy
involving old tweets of course he was
eventually rehired by Disney and after
joining forces with DC for Suicide Squad
and Peacemaker gun was able to focus on
getting Drax mantis and nebula back on
the big screen with all that drama out
of the way Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
is finally in the can so when can we
expect to see these adorable losers and
murderous Misfits Guardians of the
Galaxy volume 3 will return in all his
action-packed emotional musical glory on
May 1st 2023
there are two trailers for Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 as of the making of
this video and they promise to bring
hilarity horror heroics but mostly
heartbreak the first trailer opens with
the Guardians landing on a strange
Planet filled with humanoid animals it's
possible this could be a combination of
two different Marvel worlds counter
Earth and half world in the comics
counterwearth is a place created by the
high evolutionary while half world is a
planet filled with anthropomorphic
animals or the result of horrific
experiments after drugs makes a
hilarious and disastrous first
impression on the locals we get a
glimpse of the Guardians darling 2001 A
Space Odyssey inspired spacesuits baby
rocket about to suffer at the hands of
the high evolutionary and our hero is
preparing to make a final stand we have
been running
our whole lives
I'm done running
while the emotions are high the trailer
does end with Peter Quillen drags
debating the appropriate number of
people to kill showing these guys will
always be our lovable criminals the
second trailer released during Super
Bowl 2023 starts off by highlighting the
sticky Dynamics between pizza and this
new Gamora who has no memory of him
whatsoever as a result she doesn't
exactly reciprocate his affectionate
feelings we also get a much better look
at the high evolutionary anti-sinister
intentions which in his mind is to make
the perfect Society berta's most famous
experiment Rocket Raccoon has a
different take on the situation he
didn't want to make things perfect
hated things the way they are
also gives us everyone whose shots of
Adam Warlock in combat with the
Guardians going Toe to Toe with Drax and
what's sure to be a nail biter of a
battle
the Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 was
filmed immediately after Thor love and
thunder meanwhile director James Gunn
took on an extra project making the 2022
holiday special at the same time as the
movie Gunn confirmed that the Disney
plus special is part of the Marvel Canon
and that it actually sets the stage
quite nicely for volume 3. in Guardians
of the Galaxy holiday special we learned
several key details about the future of
our Scrappy band of space pirates
following their appearance in love and
thunder the remaining team of quill Drax
mantis nebula rockets and Crews have
moved on to continue protecting the
Galaxy the holiday special revealed that
they settled on nowhere buying the
severed Celestial head that once served
as a base for tiffan the collector in
addition to seeing some bizarre
gift-giving which included mantis and
Drax kidnapping Kevin Bacon for quill
and nebula stealing Bucky barnes's
vibranium arm for Rocket we learn
they've acquired a new ship most
importantly of although it's revealed
that mantis and Quilla actually paternal
half siblings Peter is also still
visibly Mourning the loss of Gamora who
died at thanos's hands in Infinity war
and even though an alternate version of
her traveled through time to fight
alongside them in endgame she has no
memory of Peter and ditches to Guardians
leaving Star-Lord with a broken heart we
know the Guardians are adjusting to
their new lives with villain turned hero
nebula settling into being an official
member of Quill's team according to the
official plot synopsis The Guardians
don't get much downtime as things are
upended by The Echoes of rockets
turbulent past the synopsis goes on
Peter quills still reeling from the loss
of Gamora must rally his team around him
on a dangerous mission to save Rocket's
life a mission that if not completed
successfully could quite possibly lead
to the end of the Guardians as we know
them this confirms that volume 3 will be
focused on Rocket's backstory something
gun has been hinting at for a long time
what element of Rocket's past has coming
back to haunt him all signs point to the
villainous High evolutionary his intent
on creating a perfect Society of evolved
beings by whatever torturous means
necessary we also know that Adam
warlocker power awful figure created by
the guardian's enemy The High Priestess
Aisha will factor into the story in
shorts our heroes are ready up against
them thankfully they won't be doing it
alone with the past version of Gamora
making her return she's been off leading
the ravagers filling the power vacuum
left after volume 2. both things could
get complicated if volume 3 sets up a
love triangle among Gamora pizza and
nebula this Gamora has no feelings for
Peter while he and nebula have been
growing closer as you might expect all
The Usual Suspects are returning to play
their respective Guardians roles Chris
Pratt is back as Peter Quill AKA
Star-Lord and Zoe Saldana returns as a
version of Gamora that doesn't remember
her old friends Bradley Cooper voices
Rocket Raccoon Vin Diesel portrays Groot
and Dave Batista is back as draxa
Destroyer rounding out the Old Guard
we've got pom clementieff a Star-Lord
psychic half sister mantis and Karen
Gillen as a dead-eyed assassin with a
Secret Heart of Gold nebula and
hopefully Sean gun's craglin will have
figured out how to use yondu's Arrow by
now however there's a new Guardian in
town Cosmo the space dog the telekinetic
talking poochie first debuted in the
holiday special she'll be voiced by
Maria bakalova who earned International
Acclaim and an Oscar nomination for her
turn as two-tar sagdiev in borat's
subsequent movie film on the antagonist
side of the aisle we've got chukudi
iwuji as a high evolutionary auji is no
stranger to working with James Gunn as
he previously starred as the enigmatic
Clemson man in HBO Max's Peacemaker
series with all political portray Adam
Warlock a guy who's going to give the
Guardians a pretty hard time you're no
doubt remember Paul Surfers Works in
projects like Midsummer and Black Mirror
we've also got some pretty big names
appearing in smaller side rails
Elizabeth debicky will be reprising her
role as the high priestess Aisha the
higher Mighty creator of Adam Warlock
and Sylvester Stallone returns as
ravages the car Michael Rosenbaum of
Smallville famous coming back as a
crystalline Martin X and we can't expect
to see Daniela melshore of The Suicide
Squad and Nico Santos of Superstore
some MCU heroes are inextricably tied
with their directors at this point it's
hard to separate Thor from Taiko waititi
Ryan coogler is connected to the world
of wakanda and John Watts shepherded
Spider-Man across all three films
however when it comes to a director and
their respective super franchise perhaps
no filmmaker has left a bigger impact
than James Gunn he's guided The
Guardians from the very beginning both
writing the scripts and directing the
films in addition to the Guardians
movies and the holiday special gun is
famous for his work at DC having held a
Suicide Squad and Peacemaker then of
course he became the dcu's version of
Kevin feige along with co-head Peter
Safran talking about his love of the
Guardians franchise the new DC Studios
co-head spoke to deadline about his last
Marvel project saying the reason why I
needed to finish this is because I love
the character of Rocket more than any
character I've ever dealt with before
and I needed to finish his story and
that is what volume 3 is about I
absolutely needed to do it and I think
we've done it in a spectacular way that
I can't wait for people to see while we
know Guardians of the Galaxy 3 will be
the final Guardians movie with director
James Gunn and this lineup of Heroes we
don't know which characters will die or
if any of them might come back in later
MCU movies however we do know for a fact
there's one actor who won't be returning
sadly it looks like Dave Batista is done
with playing Drax he announced he was
officially moving on from the
literal-minded destroyer in 2021 on
Ellen telling the talk show host I'm
going to be 54 years old by the time
Guardians 3 comes out the shirtless
thing is getting harder and harder for
me more that may indeed be a factor when
it comes to moving on from Marvel
Batista has given other reasons for his
departure of a more personal nature
talking with GQ Batista elaborated a bit
more in his decision saying I'm so
grateful for Drax I love him but there's
a relief it wasn't all Pleasant it was
hard playing that role the makeup
process was beating me down and I just
don't know if I want drugs to be my
legacy it's a silly performance and I
want to do more dramatic stuff will you
make a choice fans can't wait to see
what the wrestler turned legit thespian
does next as he's proven he's got
serious range with roles in films like
glasinian Blade Runner 2049 and to knock
at the cabin
with the Guardians of the Galaxy
franchise saying goodbye to Dave
Batista's dragster Destroyer it really
is the end of an era unfortunately it
looks like he might not be the only
member of the Guardians who fans will
have to Bid Farewell to in a cryptic
Instagram post who celebrated the end of
filming for Guardians of the Galaxy vol
3 back in May 2022 Scottish actor Karen
Gillen tease that nebulous story might
have come to an end she captioned
alongside a photo from the set I don't
know if nebula will return Beyond this
it's possible that this is her final
chapter and if that's the case and I
just want to say thank you to James Gunn
for giving me such an interesting
complex and fascinating character to
play I have enjoyed this exploration
more than any other character I've
played that was what a hell of a decade
thanks for watching whether nebula is
going to bite the dust in dramatic
fashion remains to be seen since
gillen's statement is rather ambiguous
but this certainly could be a final
four-way across the Galaxy of course you
never really knows someone is gone for
good when it comes to the MCU just look
at characters like Gamora and Loki so if
Gillen is open to it nebby May pop up
somewhere else in the future all good
things must come to an end and
unfortunately that also applies to the
Guardians of the Galaxy movies it's been
quite a journey since this Motley Crew
first appeared on the Cinematic scene in
2014. they've introduced us to some
groovy mixtapes saved the world with
dancing fought Kurt Russell and
kidnapped Kevin Bacon and now in volume
3 they'll be gearing up for one last
adventure as they attempt to save rocket
from his traumatic past confirming it
will be their last outing director James
Gunn told deadline this is the end for
us the last time people will see this
team of Guardians that implies we may
see some of the Guardians again or
perhaps a different iteration of the
team will show up at some point we're
assuming that some of the Guardians will
simply fly off into the Horizon they're
also assuming that some of them will die
from the trailers it looks like rocket
is going to be in some serious trouble
after running across a high evolutionary
and based on Dave Batista's comments
about moving on from the MCU it looks
like the Destroyer might also be on the
chopping block however fans shouldn't
expect a bloodbath as James Gunn said in
June 2022 this is the end of that story
I'm sorry some stories have an end it
doesn't mean everybody dies based on the
trailers it seems like the high
evolutionary will be the big bad of
Guardians of the Galaxy volume 3.
however there's another Force lurking in
the cosmos that might be an even bigger
threat Adam Warlock we've known he was
coming since the post-credits scene of
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2. early in
the film rocket gets his greedy little
paws on some analogx batteries that
belong to the Sovereign a race of
genetically modified gold aliens
consumed with vengeance The High
Priestess Aisha spends a good chunk of
volume 2 trying to kill the Guardians
and when that doesn't work out she
decides to create the perfect super
weapon Adam Warlock more powerful more
beautiful
capable of destroying the Guardians of
the Galaxy
talking about Bowser's new super being
James Gunn elaborated on warlock a bit
telling Empire the character's life
purpose is a tad more complicated than
just wiping out our band of Music loving
Heroes that said according to Gunn he's
definitely not a good guy what we're
seeing is the infant form of warlock
newly out of the Cocoon and he does not
understand life very well he's basically
a baby so are there any details we can
glean from warlock's comic book
background that might help us understand
the character going forward created by
Stan Lee and Jack Kirby Adam Warlock was
made to be a perfect being by a group
called The Enclave before he was found
drifting through space for the high
evolutionary the space scientists
essentially adopted warlock as his own
son giving him the Soul Stone and
sending him down as his representative
to counter Earth a world of the high
evolutionaries making so it's possible
we might see some sort of relationship
between the two characters in volume 3.
additionally in the comics warlock was a
huge player in The Infinity Gauntlet
storyline he was instrumental in
defeating Thanos and once it was all
said and done he became the wielder of
the Bejeweled reality altering glove for
a Time warlock was also a member of the
Guardians of the Galaxy so he has
serious comic book connections to all
the major players in volume 3. will he
be a loyal evolutionary acolyte in the
film or will he eventually side with the
Guardians we'll see how that all plays
out on May 5th 2023
the Guardians of the Galaxy franchise
just wouldn't be the same without the
Classic Rock soundtrack scoring you to
the movies James Gunn worked on these
personally listening to hundreds of
songs before creating the soundtrack for
the first movie it sounds like we can
look forward to a third playlist even
more powerful than its predecessors gun
told Entertainment Weekly I worked twice
as hard on this soundtrack as I did on
both the first two soundtracks combined
Marvel fans got their first taste of the
volume 3 soundtrack in the trailers the
second trailer features rainbows since
you've been gone the 1976 rug song
confirms that gun is bringing back more
70s hits to the franchise but he also
confirmed that since the music in this
film is coming with the Zune MP3 player
which Peter got from craglin at the end
of volume 2 rather than his mom's old
mixtapes that would explain why a hit
from 1996 in the meantime by spacehog is
featured in the first trailer release
for the film despite having life or
death Stakes for the characters
Guardians of the Galaxy movies are known
to be light-hearted funny musically
inclined superhero movies at least they
have been so far according to done the
tone of volume 3 is going to be
completely different from its
predecessors he told deadline it's big
it's so so big and dark and different
from what people might be expecting it
to be Dave Batista told up rocks that
this change in tone is going to make the
film great it's just so much better so
much deeper it's so much more personal
and there's such a massive inspiring
message to this film before even
watching a full cut of the feature he
confidently told the outlet that is
going to be the best of the three
Guardian movies that's certainly a lot
to live up to but other cast members
including Karen Gillen and palm
clementiar for also moved by the
heaviest storyline which we know will
center around rocket but involve the
rest of the cast too speaking to Digital
Spy Gillen admitted that the script was
so evocative that it brought heroin
Clementi F to tears we read it together
and we both cried and laughed but there
was four tears it's incredible I think
it's James's strongest work yet with the
Guardians and is just brilliant now
you're just making it sad however Gila
made sure to mention that there's plenty
of that classic guardian's humor in the
film soon jukudi iwoji plays a high
evolutionary a powerful villain with
virtually unlimited intellectual power
the character comes straight from the
pages of Stan Lee and Jack Kirby's comic
first appearing in Thor issue 134 a wuji
is excited to bring the character to the
big screen he told collider with great
enthusiasm he is narcissistic
sociopathic but very charming and
something very Shakespearean about him
as something very emotionally dark about
him and he's a lot of fun on top of all
of that however his casting was
unfortunately met with a cruel racist
backlash from some commenters on social
media one particular Instagram troll
criticizes portrayal of the high
evolutionary insisting the character is
supposed to be white however director
James Gunn took the opportunity to speak
out against those comments on Instagram
I chose the best actor period and the
best person for the role I didn't give
it to What ethnicity to Cudi iwuji is so
stop with your racist presumptions on
why he was chosen he also pointed out
the characters look from the comic books
adding
by the way he's playing a guy who's
almost always purple
[Music]